Kevin McCarthy caught in an episode of
The Twilight Zone
the house is now voting for the 10th
time for speaker and it appears that
he's lost again McCarthy was hoping to
break the law of jam by agreeing to
demands of the 20 conservatives voting
against him and they were offering stuff
like a lower threshold to boot McCarthy
from the speakers share more freedom
caucus members on committees and
guaranteed votes on bills conservatives
have been pushing for but so far no dice
and pressure's building on the holdouts
a little to cut a deal
well some of these members again not all
20 some of them actually have principal
disagreements which is why they're in
Kevin's office right now working them
out but some of them Sean are only
interested notoriety and fame and
attention I mean they'll never have a
gavel like Jimmy Jordan they don't have
his talent they don't have his
experience they don't work like he does
so this is their only moment to be on
National Television opposing another
Republican so whatever great ideas they
may have none of it will be done unless
there's a speaker but it may take a
while with the never Kevin crowd
isn't it time for you to pack it in in
your side of the packet in considering
he has over 200 and you have 20.
Sean I understand the frustration I
promise you but it's not frustrated you
didn't answer my question and we are
hearing we are hearing I'm not
frustrated who are still voting with
Kevin McCarthy you're not answering my
question of what we're doing and they're
cheering us on so there are more for us
than are against us and they are waiting
for Kevin to keep
Judge Jeanine we are in what it was this
day three yeah okay how does it feel how
are you feeling about all this I'm angry
about it you know why they're making the
Republicans look ridiculous first of all
I like Kevin McCarthy okay why wasn't
this done ahead of time why are we doing
this in front of the public we look like
a bunch of fools okay and Lauren bobert
you know with all due respect I mean the
woman barely won her race you're holding
out until Kevin Falls what is the
alternative what do you want what is the
option what can people agree on you want
the Republicans to vote to get the
Democrats to get a speaker of the house
can you imagine Nancy Pelosi saying let
me get some Republicans so that I can be
the speaker I can put them on committees
this is an embarrassment and and I got
to tell you that the the it's gone on
long enough it shouldn't have happened
this way he's done everything you're
lowering the threshold of Buddha to one
person to get a vote to boot him out of
Congress this guy raised a quarter of a
million dollars half these people voting
against them how much trillion he raised
a quarter of a billion dollars okay but
but
okay all right all right and these
people
people want their alternative they're
egomaniacs who've got no answers and
they ought to just be quiet and just go
along with the majority at this point if
you don't want to vote for a bill don't
vote for it that's the end of it I
shouldn't even go to you Harold you know
this is our thing we're going to keep
this in the family so I'm going to go to
Dana uh Dana your thoughts now on this
10th no vote well it's it's the longest
staring contest in history my sister and
I used to have these in the back seat of
the car and I was pretty good yeah yeah
I would not blink and that's what feels
like this is what they do everybody is
digging in and I just don't see how this
ends for a while I mean maybe they go
away for the weekend and I they didn't
take my advice nobody got a drink
together last night it's a good idea um
I do think it's interesting that he
hasn't lost Kevin hasn't lost anymore
either right so you keep getting the
same result over and over again so the
holdouts aren't getting what they want
and the 200 or so that are with Kevin
McCarthy right now are staying and it
could be that apparently there is some
progress perhaps with the ones who are
not the never cabins but the ones who
want some significant changes including
one of the things they're asking for is
to have some people jump the line of
seniority in order to get some committee
posts I mean is that is that fair I
don't know I I would imagine that if it
happened to them if they got skipped
over they'd be furious about it right
and they would say oh this is the
establishment doing this does so the the
feelings are going to get even more raw
I think as this continues on however it
just felt like there was a little
glimmer of hope that maybe this could
get done by next week I guess but I I
I'm not going to say it's not gonna I
don't think it's gonna we're pretty good
with prediction I don't know I had a
terrible year last year I've got I'm one
for one this year so far all right Greg
well you know you have a lot of dogs in
this fight uh how does this end uh well
I'm running out of things to say and so
I'm looking through my notes like what
have I what have I not said and I found
a few things so if you bear with me I'm
officially tired of people saying this
is the first time in a hundred years
this is the first time in a century you
know what else hasn't happened in 100
years 1923 yeah foreign
it's like the opposite of a Telethon you
know the sick patient gets less help
people are calling and saying we want
our donation back
this I feel bad for uh McCarthy this
cannot be good for your ego every hour
yeah you lose basically what is
literally a popularity contest it's like
Jesse this would destroy your fragile
there you go you could not handle you
would be out by the third boat this
guy's on ten he's in a national hero
who would show up every damn day to be
told we don't want you but but the point
is he does have 200 votes and these
other people all they got is 20. so it
is getting tedious you know you guys you
know you made your point you're you're
basically putting putting everybody on
notice that's good healthy quarrel we
like that it's democracy in action it's
transparent but at the same time it's
tedious we're getting bored with it
however I like that it takes up all the
time of politicians maybe this is how
all how the only thing politicians
should be doing is voting on whether
they're still a politician right that
way they'd be checking their
constituents more than checking Twitter
right if they're like they they might
Democrats might actually care about the
border and about crime if they could be
voted out every single day and maybe the
Republicans would do something about
fentanyl if if they could be voted out
every day so I say let's do this forever
and ever her and just because I want to
see Cavuto cover it every single day and
it's like so true all right Hal just
keep it short
[Laughter]
independent voters who voted for
Republicans voted for them on crime and
border inflation gas prices I can't
imagine this is what they thought they
were voting for as I think about this
and you look at it I agree with the most
if not everything that's been said
you've got 21 people
it's five percent of the Congress has
decided they're not going to allow half
of the legislative branch to be seated
and to get to work on the things that
Independents and Republicans that I
would even argue some Democrats voted
for republicans in the house to do the
Border crime inflation energy giving us
more more certainty there's some things
I agree with them that we can't get to
it seems very personal with some of
these people it's almost like every
football team and the wide receiver
looks at your girlfriend the wrong way
so you don't throw them a pass he's your
best player you're not going to throw
them a passive team
the team could win these guys seem like
they didn't get invited to the prom or
something so they're still upset about
those that didn't invite them to their
prominent they're blaming Kevin McCarthy
so what I would do if I remember Kevin
McCarthy at this point I think you have
to be serious about in all the
Republicans and Democrats have to be
serious about isolating that 21 those 21
people who don't want to be a part of
the Congress so they should all come
together and figure out whom they want
elected probably will be Kevin but Kevin
it scrapped the deals he's worked with
those 21. and go work a deal some
Democrats oh and go work a deal with
them because
he can't win without them the 201
Republicans or whatever the number is
they're the ones who should feel most
affronted by what he's doing in terms of
caving into those 21 Republicans because
they cut deals with him a long time ago
and said wait a second why are you
cutting a deal with these guys you can't
even count another vote for you he did a
deal and not one of them not one of them
has voted for him I feel a bad form in
that regard but this should have been
done to your point judge before all of
this what does he have to promise a
democrat in return does he have to put
him on a committee I mean how bad is the
is the the back and forth I don't know
but one thing I know I think for certain
if he were to deal with Democrats and
Democrats didn't uphold the deal I'd
criticize that they like to have the
Democrats the fact that more people are
not criticizing these 20 Republicans who
said if you do these things I know but
everybody's not if you do these things
we'll vote for you some people are
celebrating them as Heroes they're not
Heroes you know what they are they're
the most they're the most incompetent
cruelest deal makers I've ever seen
right they're not a deal they're not
yeah
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else